hello hello
welcome welcome
another adventure are we
hello everyone
how's everyone doing
ah
very quiet in the chat
my my no one's saying a thing
hello emorous thank you thank you thank
you
you broke the silence
I know this is uh an unusual time for
stream but I haven't streamed for a few
days
um and haven't played for a few days
so
just wanted to play for a quick hour or
hey Zayn hey we have time
hey LJ
yeah I should probably make a Twitch
account stream on there as well at the
same time
hey Bubba
this guy
yeah I don't I don't pick good times to
stream I know that
thank you
hello Martin
you guys ready for BEAST's class
Amherst what did you what more from the
game did you want
uh Bubba what's my what's your favorite
part of the game so far
um
I don't know honestly just
the addition of of law because you know
so far I would consider it to be Canon
so just expanding the universe really
new faces new spells
new places
but introduced in a nice way
what is this
what quest is this
second run my my look at you
welcome everyone
I see you've already met some of the
many beasts we studied thanks LJ I may
uh take you up on that they'll be
advised none of these
they're all oh yes
my pleasure I don't know how to handle
them
[Music]
the basics of how to care for a beast
shall we yeah this kind of Sweeting hit
the nail on the head in a lot of
different ways our new student with the
lesson today yes professor howin hello
I'm poppy poppy Sweeting
don't worry about Professor her
character looks ridiculous I know you
can change their parents I know you can
change
pay attention please the tongue of a
puff skin can be a slippery devil I've
been taking my time with uh
with the main quests you can
thanks for tuning in bubba I appreciate
it use my brush thanks for the support
oh and think Plus
yeah multiplayer would be nice I did a
video on DLC I'd like to see
uh how do I
I wasn't paying attention what do I do
ah
that's lovely I'm sure he feels much
better
he might be hungry
would you mind giving him some Beast
feed
um I haven't seen anything that
contradicts Cannon yet no
to think I'm sure I'll see something we
can safely say that Gerald
probably something minor because I as
far as I can tell they did a really good
job with this
right after ambition
and cleanliness
if they do try wizard tournament DLC
though that will contradict Canon
because there was no try and wizard
tournament between 1792 and 1994. read
and groom them
that's one thing to keep in mind don't
you show our new student to the measles
in the farthest pen
this way the knees yeah like I think if
it contradicts Canon it's in subtle ways
that I think we can forgive
given the size of the game
oh coupling these or whiskers or to get
me a few cannots at least enough to buy
something once everyone else's uh
favorite part of the game
stupid thing
absolutely Bubba yeah
yeah you can tell this wasn't just
random game development I mean I think
that was sort of the problem with a lot
of the old Harry Potter games is that
they
they weren't consistent with Canon
they're kind of all over the place
let's go
[Music]
no you don't want a continuation
I don't know
I think I would mind that
near this class
approaches and training Russian easel
feet and easily
yeah I don't know how'd they do that
thanks K young butter
I'm uh I'm gonna do another video on
Merlin soon
he lucky hey Roto
what's the PG for the game oh I don't
even know
time has come to an end please
yourselves out now where is our new
student
ah there you are
I would like please lucky my day was
good thank you how was yours
just did some some housekeeping
um in terms of video organization
turns out I've got uh what is it
790 video ideas in a document
which I was sorting through and trying
to categorize
that's what happens when you have a
Harry Potter channel for four years
hello professor you wanted to speak with
me I did uh I'd probably rather be a
Ravenclaw than a Hufflepuff listen
it was wonderful I believe yeah I don't
stream it normal hours and I don't
schedule the streams
that's fine they can play a vital role
in our lives some provide us with
magically imbued materials I'm not known
for my streams correctly which does not
include torturing them for whiskers
well done by the way yes Professor
stumbling over dead beasts surely the
poachers can be brought hmm an Optimum
professor
so meanwhile I oh
hey over here come on
hey true sighted
hey red Corvin
790 video ideas
do you need something poppy thank you
again for saying something to those yeah
I think um other games I'm sorry sorry
um other schools would be amazing hope
that's a good thing an expansion with
each new school I mean that seems like
an obvious awesome to include and that's
sort of an area of Canon that isn't
explored too much so there's lots of
them you know lots of room for uh
creativity
[Music]
act I'd like you to meet in the forest
you've intrigued me I'd hoped I would
what is this is this going to be
Buckbeak
or hippogriff of some variety just
anyone there
look it will be really well thank you I
think
as I said bloody think alike pleasant
surprise
bloodies hardly a curse word
quite the weather we're having don't you
think poppy where are you taking me
um I live in Canada so it's two in the
morning for me
one Pacific time
I'm from England but I live in Canada
English accent
stand back
Hogwarts Legacy TV series
Dan uh yeah I'm not really trying to
rush through the game I mean
I just want to enjoy myself
and uh I've got videos to make so I
can't believe playing Hogwarts Legacy
all day
isn't she just magnificent
I'd rather
go on you know take my time and be
careful
I'm sure I'll beat it before the next
expansions come out because they do so
before you approach them
yeah yeah I'll
I'll regret it if I rush through
yeah they could do a prequel that might
do well
you know Founders or Tom Riddle this
quickly
you can feed a brush over you'd like
I come and check on her every once in a
while bring her pasties tell her what's
going on
you wouldn't know from looking at her
but she's a dreadful busybody
yeah the the longer you take
the longer it lasts
very profound
I'm in no rush
[Music]
so what did you think of Highway
I thought she was brilliant can't
believe you introduced me to her I
suspected you two might get along I
he's flying above the Forbidden Forest
it's trust they'll always be there for
you I've seen it firsthand with her how
exactly did you and high Wing cross
paths it's a longer story hey James I'm
glad the glasses have improved
got her to safety and well she was yeah
young Dumbledore TV series I think Young
Snape would be really good or something
of a problem in the area
mentioned the poachers as well
he seemed to imply that we couldn't rely
on the ministry to help I don't often
agree with Professor howin but on that
the poacher's influence is growing I see
them every day in the village lingering
talking to people they're up to
something I'm just not sure what
or live longer
what do you mean Thunder God
thanks Dan
hey Darcy welcome
where's Star Wars Theory uh he's at home
uh uh Hey Thor son of Odin
you may be reading into it
talking to people isn't a crime it's
hard to explain but
I think I need to update my
clothing
uh okay let's get some poachers guys no
idea information is power and the more I
know
I'm always worried I'm saying everyone's
name wrong will you let me know what you
find out oh very well I will I should be
going but we'll speak again soon
oh was that a main quest
I'm good thank you
good night crippled thanks for tuning in
so do I have a quest to go kill some
poachers now
I must
oh my goodness I have so much to do
uh
what question I do guys
foreign
ERS in one show yep they could they
could do they could just do it could
start with young Snape and you know show
young snake with young Lily and then
show them going off to Hogwarts and then
introduce the Marauders
after playing this game I watched
Fantastic Beasts and Harry Potter all
over again yep absolutely
I was watching Harry Potter in the ramp
up to this
you can hide parts of your clothes and
change its appearance yep yep yep I know
I'm just changing gear quite often so
American Spirit Maybe
too Shaw I'm your biggest fan I've seen
every single video of yours thank you
thank you thank you thank you
do some assignments maybe Sharps explore
some assignments okay I'll do Professor
shops assignment how's that
should probably uh
equip something else
what other streams would you guys like
to see you know besides
um Hogwarts Legacy stuff because I mean
I'm not just gonna stream Hogwarts
Legacy forever
and uh now that I'm getting a little
more comfortable with the live streams
I'll do some other stuff
thanks Dan
appreciate that
thanks Linda God
Lego Harry Potter I thought about maybe
playing the PlayStation one
kind of start from there and
go through the games probably take me 10
years though to go through all the games
at my pace
other games here
am I tracking this Quest
yeah I've got a video coming out
tomorrow on the history of Avada Kedavra
with some theories about it and then
I've also got a video coming out on
Ancient Magic
which will be out
on Sunday
so history of Ivana cadavra
uh coming out in sort of 10 11 hours and
then
history of ancient Magic
I enjoy your videos and just want to say
thank you for explaining Harry Potter
history thanks trip
each Schmidt oh you got the game nice
here yeah I remember you tuning in
before and saying you're about to get it
how was it
more stuff to do
will I be using the unforgivable curses
in the game yep
maybe you can do a poll on what to play
yeah good idea
there's problems with streamlabs uh not
myself
level 21 yeah I've done the first trial
too that's about as far as I've gotten
foreign
which Quest is this what am I doing
one second guys
foreign
there we go
oh I have to go to hogsmeade
that makes sense thanks Royal
let's pop on over to hogsmeade then
foreign
that's strange
I don't know
who lived here I wonder
foreign
s just wondering the ground exploring
and finding the pages yep yep yep yep
I don't think cursed child will become a
film
to be honest with you
um any rumors regarding that um not true
that same rumor comes out multiple times
a year every year
it's ridiculous
no no no no
[Music]
they are not the same
diagonally uh would be a cool addition
to the game plenty to look at here
hey thanks so much Dan
I appreciate that thank you thank you
Rebellion
thank you guys for watching
which is the potion shop I'm so bad at
navigating everything
drip you're so much further ahead of me
the last time
yeah I I guess I made some progress
trip to Azkaban
how you finding the game love it
Port key will make a fortune in DLCs
yeah yeah what what DLCs would you guys
like to see top three comment your top
three
skip conversation
oh sure yeah yeah I won't
thanks minty
come on in healing potions of a
specialty here should you need any
I hope to see you again farewell for now
what do I need from this from this man
I need
Focus potion Maxima adores
Focus
Maxima adurus
what can I do for you today
a wise decision thank you
oh didn't need to buy the
recipes did I
wise decision
thank you
well there you go got no money left
yeah that's true can I sell them what
are they worth
no you can't sell them I should sell
some stuff though
um
yeah sixth and seventh year DLC would be
good
um I don't know about the Discord yet I
haven't thought about it but I will
quidditch Wizard's Chest Diagon Alley
yeah yep yep
hey chicken thank you thank you
uh I haven't listened to the new Ariana
Grande remix with the weekend no I
haven't
what can I do for you today
interesting question
yeah more uh cross ones would be good I
enjoyed that
stalks replenish oh nope
oh an identified item
I gotta identify that
I got some stuff to equip
apparently
there's all this stuff
better than what I have
I hope to see you again farewell for now
yeah I'll go there
um who wants Ariana if you have a
bombardo spells exactly
much cheaper to make them yourself yep
yep yep
Deathly Hallows DLC
Patrick
I'm so disappointed I only just realized
you've been streaming this now
it's okay
it's not too late
this is only the beginning and I'm what
13 done with the game
foreign
outfits
damn
it looks good
um what talent trees did you guys build
what can I do for you today
yeah these all of all the streams so far
are saved on the channel
um just go to the main Channel page and
click live and they should be there
I've done seven I've done this is the
eighth
liger
Revan just finished my first play
through as a Slytherin the game was a
plus great story exactly
the whole Clump juice does sound good
um
oh did I not equip these glove glow I
hope to see you again farewell let's see
the gloves let's see the gloves where
are they
there we go
make a sequel game
what can I do for you today they made a
sequel gaming we got to meet a young
Dumbledore I'd love that
I love it
he's supposed to be a prodigy
from basically his first year at
Hogwarts so
but his family had a bad reputation
because of his father initially
but then he kind of overshadows that
because he was so excellent I hope to
see you again farewell for now
um
I see more PC optimization have the UI
changed to affect PC player I'd like to
be able to zoom out
I mean I don't like the field of view
but this is I'm stuck with this
[Music]
finish the game the other day as a
Hufflepuff
yeah I know
and there's so much demand I mean when
people say there isn't going to be a
isn't going to be DLC
they're nuts
no you can't edit uh field of view in on
PlayStation
at least you couldn't before unless
they've patched that
yeah that's just PC
yeah it's it's far too zoomed in
Patrick have to admit I would absolutely
adore if you've got more info on
Aleister Moody
yeah well I'll I'll make a video on him
if if you want
I'm in Slytherin yet
yeah I hate how zoomed I am bothers me a
lot
okay so I have to use a focus potion
foreign
how do you equip a different potion
um yeah yeah zooming out would would
make fighting a lot easier as well
honestly
um I'd love a sequel to this and see
what happens to the characters
companions later in life yeah
to lack
I really like your voice thank you
L1
uh which one is
which one do I have to use Focus
did that equip it
oh yes it did
okay
Maxima and a duras and use them
simultaneously
my goal is to play all four houses I
finished grieving with my house I'm
right now doing Ravenclaw common room so
pretty it is
equipment wheel
yeah how do I use both potions at once I
just have to equip it use it and then
equip the other one and use it
foreign
my goodness
I'm still getting the hang of the
PlayStation controller
not uh quickly yeah
Alex
too a dash of powdered back spleen I
think
who's my favorite Professor
um
I don't know fig
Maybe
the morality system would be good
[Music]
yeah it would be
will I be using the unforgivable curses
yes I will
if you don't know close to a flu powder
spot to fast travel
hold L1
right yeah I always forget that
you can get run stress ropes can you how
do you get Ron's dress robes
ignatia wild Smith is the uh which who
invented flu powder
and I'm actually going to do a video on
all of the Hogwarts portraits and who
they are but it's a big undertaking so
it's going to take me a while
Ben am I enjoying the game so far
absolutely
how are your assignments coming along I
completed your assignments Professor
good
you should be ready to learn to pulso
let's see what you can do who's
everyone's favorite character from
concentrate the main story Harry Potter
yeah I got a PlayStation for this game
I hadn't had a console if you'd like to
practice and I think you should perhaps
best not to go flinging your classmates
about the halls I suggest having a go
with the enchanted book here
Rebellion
[Music]
she's it
depulso
well done I'm glad to see that you seem
staunchly determined to master your
spellcasting Snape is your favorite
Bellatrix yeah Voldemort fave
what I always found interesting about HP
is how everyone is basically they're in
love with how I absolutely hate him yeah
future Dr Gigi your voice is perfect for
talking about all things Harry Potter
love it thank you thank you
I bought a Snape cardboard cut out I
have a Dumbledore cardboard cutout
I'll put it in a video soon
uh Sirius is one of my favorites
yeah that's fair
do I have to do anything else for this
Quest what am I
what am I supposed to be doing now
repetition
Rebellion
okay I'm done okay
I'm trash at games
if you didn't notice
I'm okay at fighting but I'm no good at
the rest
foreign
there we go
house token
is cool
[Music]
it's late night for me KP
okay what should I do now I think I have
a an owl mail from
Sebastian
or something from Sebastian
don't I no I don't
what quest should I do now
chat which which Quest
tell me
no I'm from the UK but I live in Canada
I don't think we can go to Azkaban yet
isn't that just a Hufflepuff Quest
do I have a Sebastian Quest
should I do this the Helm of
I don't want to do Professor garlic
is this an interesting Quest
the helm I'll do the helm
yeah
no I haven't fallen off the poachers how
do you get the poacher's quest
foreign
it's all part of the fun
I need some action guys
make sure to give this stream a like if
you enjoy it
please pretty please
where do all of you guys live
what country
I think we've got a mix in here probably
Poland OH
India Poland
us Netherlands East Coast U.S UK India
Netherlands us Germany Austria Pakistan
Marissa welcome
your back's okay
thanks KP
oh Italy very nice Renee
look at the diversity guys
look at that huh
[Music]
it's 2 45 a.m for me
hello there nice to see you
pardon me but were you saying something
oh hello talking to myself no I haven't
been back to the UK for a while I think
it's been
the precious over five years
planning on going when I was at Hogwarts
we truly forbidden from entering the
forest in September told horrible
stories about it and I've had an
irrationally intense fear dantuania
I was down to in this time of year but
I'm insane
welcome bill go in the forest
You couldn't possibly find out could you
you want me to follow the butterflies I
thanks Kobe
very well
if I have time I shall see where they
lead
where did the butterflies lead in this
Quest so much does it spoil it if I ask
you guys
do I want to follow the butterflies
don't forget the butterflies always seem
to be on the fringes of the forbidden
okay I'm not gonna do that one
to treasure I'll do it I'll do it later
yeah follow the spines
hello Miss Ryan
I wanted to thank you again for your
help with Rookwood and Harlow the day of
the troll attack sirona please
and I was happy to help
those two are nothing but trouble
glad you and your friend were here when
they found you I am too
you were speaking to a goblin here that
day yes Lord
he's a friend
I was surprised that you seemed friendly
with a goblin I've known him for years
we met when I was waiting tables here as
a student well before I bought the place
he was cordial enough but we weren't
friends then his mistrust of wizard kind
ran deep but you're friends now we are
hadn't seen him in years when he came in
a few months ago but he recognized me
instantly to chests which is more than I
can say for some of my own classmates
okay
I was actually a witch not a wizard not
all goblins are like Round Rock and his
loyalists blood Gog is as worried as the
rest of us about what's been going on
gotcha in that case I'd like to talk
with him about ran Rock in particular
I assume your interest is to do with the
rumors I've heard about Rand Rock
working with our friend Rookwood it is
if he's not here you might find him
doing business at the hog's head
and you should mention that we spoke
he can understandably be wary of witches
and wizards even what that said If
you're looking for information on ran
Rock to help break
thank you sirona if you're fine what's
everyone's favorite film I don't know
what you've done to make such powerful
enemies
but please
watch your back
just the right
welcome back I've arranged a special
prize on the brim upgrade for you I
truly appreciate all of your help
is this part of the quest
yep I must tell you half of oxmead's
been by the shop asking about rumors of
a brome upgrade without the information
you provided my work would have taken
twice as long thank you again Order of
the Phoenix I've already begun work on
another I wondered would you be
interested in joining forces again if
you were to test this first upgrade
there it may help me as I develop the
next yeah Order of the Phoenix is one of
my favorites and then probably
philosopher's stone
sounds as if you're really out doing
Nostalgia if I'm able to help I will
thank you I know this recent success was
only the beginning Aura of the Phoenix
was just felt like multiple movies in
one as soon as you can and we'll be Off
to the Races
to start poached egg
poached egg Quest talk to Poppy
Off to the Races then I'm supposed to go
to the hog's head
ourselves
second favorite is older yeah
I'll do the Poetry quest after this
least favorite is definitely Hallows
part one yeah it was okay I don't know
it wasn't bad
I saw um the the hell is part one and
two with a live Orchestra
um this past summer which was amazing
so they play the score of the film while
it's playing in the background on a
projector
Hello Lord
sirona said I might find you here yes
she did did she did she send you with
news no actually I wanted to speak with
you
it's about Round Rock
now I remember the three broomsticks
Dave he looks friendly you're the
student he's after I am not being
facetious I need to know what he and his
loyalists are up to so I can stay a step
ahead let's say I did know why should I
trust you
sironus that our interests may be
aligned
perhaps she was wrong hmm
well if sirona believes we have common
goals then it is possible that we can
trust each other very well I may know of
yeah I think they're definitely hello
my least favorite hide his plans to me
Harry Potter films I mean years ago
least favorites of the franchise that I
love
a while back The Relic could Well Repair
the chasm between us
problem with Deathly Hallows one was it
was just really slow and depressing yeah
it was a bit
very well I'll retrieve The Relic if you
promise to share we will have to trust
each other I that you will not abscond
with the Relic and you that I'll share
what gather whatever supplies you may
need and meet me near the witch's tomb
to get this Quest you need to have done
fire enough fire and vice Dragon debris
from Professor Weasley's assignment have
I done it
I must have if I'm getting the quest
right
yeah I didn't like the uh
the ending for The Elder Wand in the
films
no no no
I'm ready
good there's no time to lose
what precisely is The Relic on to
retrieve I couldn't get into Percy
Jackson I tried
as per which considered herself a
collector lots of recommendations
a lot of Greek mythology
of any object is its maker not its
purchaser was it go and see things
differently
it's a wonder goblins and wizards have
ever been able to skip 90 of dialogue no
I'm reading it I just don't wait for
them to say it let's read it
may surprise
that I do not believe
D to be in
cement it is the reason I find myself
traveling with you to this tomb today
oh
saddest moment in Harry Potter for me is
when we see Snape's memories yeah
probably
Marcin need to go back to work nice to
hear you live keep going with the
channel thank you thank you
honestly nearly idea me too but it's
been a while
what do we have down here
oh we've got a trial of Merlin
oh yes okay thank you James or Revan
sorry
good to know
is this thing far
uh I have done a video on Merlin yeah
but
I could update it now
so I'm gonna do another one and there it
is the witch's tomb Dreadful looking
place isn't it I've done a video on
Merlin I've done a video on Morgana
history of each of them
I wish you luck retrieving the helmet
now before you set off do you have any
questions
the stream rules yeah
don't worry the ld1 can be repaired with
the elduanta exactly
it's so special the helmet of earthcot
is an ancient and storied Relic forged
during it hey Jonah Unity among the
goblin Clans it inspired greatness that
is until it was no longer ours then it
became something else
a symbol of what has been lost
and it was weird
Voldemort reclaiming it would mean a
broken two million pieces
he would be grateful to me should I
return it
I kind of hoped he would have just died
the same way as everyone else like a
normal human death
Nelson you finish the game
amazing
it all seems clear to me now that we're
here I do hope our alliance proves
fruitful again I wish you luck
love the game I will remain here eagerly
awaiting your return please be careful
uh I don't know if you've answered this
in a video already but why was the money
up I've made an entire video on that
you've got to watch it because it's
quite a comprehensive quite
incomprehensive answer
how do you feel about the Fantastic
Beasts films I like them
yeah yeah um I mean they're not as good
as the original films but
there's something you know I think I
gave them all kind of like a seven out
of ten ish and I thought the last one
was an improvement
so I think they were heading right they
were heading in the right direction
um a lot about lost in the last puzzle
maybe Marissa yeah is this a long
dungeon
uh cursed child is me
baths
it's curious
exactly Patrick yeah I know that was
that was important it was an important
component of his death so the film's
kind of
they uh they dropped the ball on that
oh I know what I need do I need
thank you
Rebellion
lumos uh okay
ah yes because moths like
light right lumos
now what
what happens now
what did I have in my
triangled before
it was uh experienced yeah that's bad
who did I ship before the books were
finished
I didn't really do any shipping to be
honest
maybe I don't know
cursed child very much so felt like it
wasn't real Harry Potter yeah yeah I
agree with that yeah I would give the
cursed child
like a like maybe not even a five
like a four
no I don't have the extra cost groups no
no
um you mean the talent you mean
should I get that
it's a core teller isn't it
oh maybe I do have it do I
yeah I've got it okay so
how do I use this thing
R2 and tap in a direction to swap and
unlock spellset
thanks for gov
okay how do I do that
see you James thanks for tuning in
if you unlock the one below you'll get
more I end up with two sets for combat
oh I see okay so this one I'll do
I don't know
what should I do for this one
was it is this the main one
okay so this is gonna be my main one for
combat
this one I'll have
lumos
you're so accio
I don't have that many spells to be
honest
I see okay cool
now we get it
this can't be the witches too
likely I need to go further
lumos
where's the other butterfly
is it in a different room
must be
flying car mount yeah
aha okay let me
that's true it is
I got the booze to have my absolutely
you need to work on to enjoy and check
out your other walkthrough been tough
for years blood birth channels thanks
Chris
have a good one
the Pulsar oh depaulser okay
well
nice nice nice
lumos
revelio
I have a feeling I'm not alone here uh
oh what have we got here now in Ferry
if I need some uh some fire for these
guys right
freedom
when you fire damage right there are
more of them in here should I uh
should I equip another fire spell
3M some idiot just set off the fire
alarm back in a bit damn that's annoying
Cube see you uh in a bit
then ship the Dead
um
how do I get up there
is there an object I can move to climb
up
thank you
Rebellion
does anyone know how I can get that
chest
okay well it's not important right now
try to climb
yeah it's not going so well
no
there's nothing it's okay uh oh
I'll do it after oh maybe I won't
um
lumos
love yourself
okay oh bones is that what it is oh
back here
if I could power it somehow it looks
like it could be rotated
a butterfly to the statue in the middle
lumos
aha
and then what
this has a moth imprinted on it
same as the doors
foreign
lumos
oh
let me open
lumos
thanks guys
what is this thing doing
lumos
there we go
very nice
revelio
what's that
looks precarious
sorry it's a balancing act trying to
read chats and play and solve puzzles
I am not used to it
down I go no other way is that the way
revelio
oops what do we have here
is this more chests
also
love yourself
how do you flip the Box
oh like that oh nice
very clever
isn't there another one yes there is
accurate
can I attach to something
you know what let's just do this
back here
there we go
oh no oh nice
okay on with the quest
oh
oh my goodness puzzle off to puzzle
after puzzle
lumos
thank you
my my more of them
couldn't find them
it wasn't too bad
yeah I always forget to use Ancient
Magic
I didn't really need it though
lumos I guess it's fun to use
so there's that
whoops too high
lumos
thanks smiggly
I don't know I'm okay
um
this looks even more complex
okay
lumos
there we go
oh there's another one
I didn't even see him lumos
is it just three
okay so do you have to just run quickly
oh
good whoops oh no I forgot to get him
uh
he does this
hmm
what's the order of operations here
you can say you can say it
making this spin or to raise that
platform
that must be it
if you cast lumos at the top will they
come no
de pulso lumos
and then go there
what are you guys talking about
lumos
no which wait what are you guys what are
you talking about
the Pulsar then go left to the door
foreign
oh
I see
the Pulsa then go left
because I don't want the butterfly and
then they finally pick it up on top
where's this other
butterfly statue
also
am I supposed to jump on this
oh I see I see what you're saying
oh
I'm obviously not getting it
foreign go here
I have no idea
what's happening guys
yeah but where do I go
also
and then I go on this
why do I go on that what does this have
to do with anything
foreign
I don't understand
I'll look it up
there's a butterfly in the other side of
the room
foreign
I didn't see that
lumos
oh okay yeah I didn't see this one
lumos oh oh from the top from the top I
see I see I see
wait do I
take them off to the pedestal then you
go up it spin it
and grab it
wait no this is this is this one
lumos
goodbye Rosie
oh
that's it okay I didn't even realize
there was another Mall
oh my goodness I feel like an idiot
lumos
thank you thank you thank you thank you
I didn't see that other moth I just
missed it
which is final resting place
Lord said the helmet was eating
hustle yeah the puzzle did suck
that would have taken me ages
I think I'm uh I guess I'm getting tired
oh compatriots must have made off with
the helmet I've got one like this
show this to lodgok
hey eon
is that it
must be some sort of mechanism for this
doorway took you an hour yeah
that was a complicated puzzle
I just didn't see that other butterfly I
just didn't see it
okay where is he there he is
Lord gok the sarcophagus had been raided
I found no helmet only a dead ashwinder
damn they got here first we need to get
it before Rookwood uses it to further
ingratiate himself to Rebellion I saw
one of their campsites not far from here
but I fear you must go in alone my
fighting days are behind me
I'll head there now good there's no time
to lose get to that helmet before
Rookwood does or we will lose our chance
at any leverage no matter how yeah the
inferior just reanimated corpses nothing
I mean zombies have their hands on such
a relic
foreign
ers
you will not survive this fight
oh my goodness look at this
news
oh my goodness wow
let the ocean
potato
ES
ouch
send you
there we go
dude your vids are invading my
recommended so hard good to hear
of the invisible spell you're gonna need
it the amount of Avada cadaver
that'd be in this game and multiplayer
when the trolls are hit hard I think
flying smoke fight towards you would be
cool
I'm sleepy now I have to go get some
sleep have a good night Mitty
it wasn't too bad
honestly
foreign
is there anything else
is this uh
not the right place
foreign
oh
good
okay what's next
is there a bridge there
the other way oh
oh
this way okay
it's this way
who's my favorite Harry Potter character
um
maybe Dumbledore
maybe Snape
revelio
up there
is that where you want me to go
oh oh
okay I see
that's it
I'll make you wish
[Music]
I'm not done with you
foreign ER
revelio
2 13. what did I just hit
I don't know how I missed that shack I'm
missing everything I think I'm just
tired it's time for bed after this
I'm missing everything
not very perceptive right now
I wonder if I'm safe to explore in there
I retrieved the helmet from the
ashwinders well done this is sure to
impress Round Rock
helmet shines even more brightly than I
imagined the etchings the Contour of the
profile remarkable
it just looks like a helmet to me ah
you're looking at what it is rather than
what it means to most goblins this is
more than a mere helmet you did the
thieves
um
thank you this should earn round Rockets
immediately it may distract him from his
search his search it does it is merely
an Inkling
you have impressed me great I think I've
played like 10 hours I'm glad that I
trusted you
we should speak
s quiet for now
leave with our aims might possibly be
alive
okay guys
uh I'm done for the evening I am getting
tired but I'll be back
in a couple of days
um
there's a video coming out tomorrow
and then on Sunday
I will stream and another video will
come out
thanks for the help guys and uh thanks
for tuning in I'll uh I'll see you all
again soon
thank you thank you have a good night
guys or have a good day depending on
where you are
sorry I suck at this
foreign